i'm a little wary of the idea that we  should think of that as a microcosm for  what should happen for black america  because not because i'm against  reparations but because reparations for  black america already happened starting  in the late 60s affirmative action was  reparations people didn't use that word  but that's precisely what it was it's an  affirmative action didn't help to turn  black america upside down then why do we  fight red tooth claw and nail whenever  anybody threatens it it created a huge  black middle class and it created black  success of all kinds that wouldn't have  happened without it i think affirmative  action was a great thing but i do think  that it was a reparation  i love this argument i love the angle  he's taking here because he's saying  look some kind of reparation  is perhaps justified  now should we have reparations hundreds  of years later uh i think that  argument's a little weaker but  to me the cleverer argument is we've  already had